[Music]
at last you know yeah my goal is to get
you to sing on camera you've already
done it you're a natural
let's go girls tonight has been a huge
inspiration for me as she has for a lot
of people especially all of the people
who might feel like they're in the
margins of country music and Breeland
even got the Shania stamp of approval on
his song Natural which samples her Smash
Hit Man I Feel Like a Woman
[Music]
get a country girl well she just did an
interview a couple days ago and they
asked her what new songs she's been
listening to and she mentioned natural
as one of those songs so I was geeked
what I'm trying to do with this whole
cross-country movement is largely
inspired by Shania and wouldn't be
possible without her
[Music]
let's talk about your album you have
well I mean it's fitting I just like to
catch it in the moment you know I don't
get called out too often I think I'm
cool but then
and we have to talk about the star
static collabs on cross country like
Thomas Rhett Keith Urban lady a and
Mickey Guyton all of these people have
accomplished a lot all of these people
have done a lot in their careers and the
impact that their careers have had on
millions of people and myself included
is is pretty striking but what about a
future collab with the queen of country
Shania Twain we are just putting it out
into the universe
[Music]